on a mis des tee-shirts on va aller les
t-shirts ça peu ridicule en fait on les
a ça les a cramé avec leur a reversé
aux lésés le faire nous mêmes on les a
cramé au fer à repasser et en plus on
dirait des polos de deux vendeurs non
retour est vendeur de route et de garage
de voitures bonjour je suis obligé de
carglass
normalement en trois parties de l'europe
à ce pool souhaitons pas que lappartient
s'il y avait déjà
ce et pourrait bien vous qui tourne
[Musique]
tout ce
temps je connais pas ce système
d'abord
parce que je vais tirer
on
peut partir la ferraille il serait mieux
chez le ferrailleur
non
en photo il ya un problème ces chiens
allez je prends les paris
bassin pas l'air d'être aussi lourd
qu'un vélo trottinette allés au bout
d'eux seuls
pour ce voiture bateau
le bateau
alors là mais beaucoup de plastique
alors
rattachée faire aujourd'hui nous ce
qu'il en est
bédard 10 heures
moi j'espère que c'est un peu mieux que
les deux des deux précédents ouais même
si ça sera sûrement est dans la même
lignée on va voir ça tout de suite
découvert qu'en direct
c'est l'autre partie à 5 un postulat
ouais super c'est quand même première
avoir beaucoup de si gros
c'est pas sûr qu'il indique encore la
bonne température
voir
ça se tient le minimum pour moi belpech
non c'est devenu un niveau à bulle bon
eh bien j'espère que ça autre pied du
barbecue parce que là en fait il nous
manque trois pieds pour réussir à
reconstituer un barbecue si on a les
trois on va vraiment répondre au jeu le
faire aurait essayé de vraiment le faire
sont à l'étroit
même si on n'y sera plus à gaspard
comptera ce sera oui
bah oui c'est le pied
c'est bien ce qu'on pensait
ouais
ça je sais pas
je vais très goûté de gaz allez ça alors
par contre pour le remonter ça va être
compliqué du coup ça va il faudrait
souder un peu quoi regardante est temps
at on a tout manqué la bouteille
est super on a un problème avec la star
si vous savez ce qu'il faut faire dans
ces cas là mais il fait le peu chien
d'arrêt kg j'ai pas l'impression qu'il
en a un peu marre de la paix chez qui le
rend très
content pour lui mais clairement sa mort
sont encore du barbecue en fait j'avais
indiqué super bon cette fois et ce qu'il
en reste
rose pas
besoin de toucher le petit un truc à
part ça aussi c'est plein regard hagard
ouais bah oui tout
un
chacun
oui
mais
la vraie question c'est comment passer
les péniches
oui
[Rires]
barbecue ou vélo du coup barbecue
jamais aucun sens
juste dit qu'il me fallait un barbecue
oui oui oui barbecue
le même tiroir y ressemble
voyez plusieurs tiroirs
le gang des voleurs de barbecue
j'ai quelque chose encore mais qu'a
lancé une sortie
c'est ça
c'est la débandade des pieds mes pieds
pour le deuxième
but d'avoir vécu
ça change les armes
ils mangent les âges non
mais la seule où il est petit
c'est ballot
non
originalité bon regardez la belle
trouvaille
1 prévient encore et ben bâtisse il
déteste parce que je m'en sers pour
trépied de caméra et là en plus il
manque un pied donc ça fait encore plus
chiant
bon du coup c'est mon deuxième mais dans
mon genre à mettre le pied qui manquent
petit trépied de pêcheurs qui nous pèse
quoi des barbecues ou encore
teddy tant qu'on n'a pas fait les deux
barbecues complet on ne bouge pas
c'est pas qu'on peut plus
moi je suis très bien je suis posé en
train de filmer ses salles du cuivre oh
c'est bon ça
c'est le début de la richesse dégâts
j'étais à metz était à manger c'était
carrément garantie reste du pâté dedans
non si c'est de la bouffe c'est bien de
la grèce pour nettoyer au poste pas tant
que ça c'est l'épongé c'est qu'on leur
bac
si lui y voit la bouffe la highway
fait qu'elle et merguez au fond ah ouais
vous pensez qu'on peut pêcher les
merguez avec véhémence moi je pense ça
se tente on a déjà fait bien pire
il ya du poids aïe aïe ça bougeait
encore
[Musique]
c'est oui
les pieds et l'élan vers un barbecue
ils entier
ah oui là c'est voir bons élèves comme
ça
pendant pas non plus sortir de l'eau il
est très bien comme ça ça fait un petit
peu le forme pour les pêcheurs saute
dessus vas-y meilleures vaches et de
cassis ouais c'est clair qu'à
l'intérieur allez on va le chopper
regarde on apprécie pour un style à
repérer
[Applaudissements]
ouais non
pas ça fait le taff 1 ça fait le taf
ouais ouais non c'est pas mal au final
ah oui la lentille je crois il doit
manquer que le couvercle comme une bombe
mais je pense que cela a fait ce qu'il a
sur les bateaux de l'eau quand c'est
possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
designed in france elle a dû passer
quelques mois dans l'autre deuxième
série classique si vous avez le même
barbecue
était qu'à ses boutons
ouf bon bah voilà la vidéo touche à sa
fin donc c'est barbecue c'est très
louche mais on nous a dit que c'est
parce que les péniches passe sous lbo et
elle tape donc les barbecues tombe mais
on n'écarte quand même pas l'hypothèse
d'un gang de
je terre-neuve accuse donc à suivre à
suivre à suivre en misant
voilà donc en pleine restauration du
barbecue pêcher à les membres est un
petit peu rires
regardez voir comment certains ça
revient à bien régler il est bien payée
pour faire des grillades fasse pas trop
gênant ça va voilà on a allumé le petit
barbecue au gaz a été convertie bien sûr
converti en barbecue à voir bon pas trop
ce mot là tu vas mettre le feu écoute
pour une fois c'est une pêche qui sert
tout de suite fait ça alors là la
restauration a été plutôt rapide vous
soit faire nous c'est qu'on restera une
bonne grillade et comment c'est l'apéro
et on se dit ah la semaine prochaine
pour de nouvelles vidéos de pêche à
leyment avec je l'espère cette fois ci
on tourne chat ou une friteuse